I only just forgot Calvary has our names
and addresses just wrong
I was like Angela please please we go
too fast
Vanity's conspiracy of Atocha bang your
head would spawn
what is this
it's the only way to show you the truth
you need to help stop the seventh
cavalry from doing what those are
Krishna trying to start a war
[Music]
well it looks like you got things under
control here full costume
Thanks welcome back everyone it's
Charlie this is gonna be my non-spoilery
Watchmen episode 1 review I've had a
chance to see an early version of the
episode so we'll break it down I'll
explain some context for when the series
takes place relative to the previous
Watchmen story if you've seen the movie
or if you read the original comic book
they're 9 episodes total instead of the
usual 10 you would expect from a
traditional HBO series but I will be
doing weekly episodes in Easter Egg
videos be sure to subscribe if you're
brand new to my channel I will do weekly
giveaways to either for HBO now or for
the comic book series or anything you
guys want important context for the
series though this is meant to be a
sequel series to the original Alan Moore
comic book not the movie the movie
changed some things about the original
comic book so a lot of things that are
referenced during episode 1 when they
sort of catch you up to speed on what
the world is like in present day it's
the present day of the comic book not
the movie it takes place in present day
2019 so it's been 35 years since
Adrienne Veet Ozymandias portal in a
giant alien squid de Manhattan killing
millions of people in his attempt to
bring about world peace if it's been a
long time since you saw the movie or you
didn't read the comic book quick
explainer for how the comic book ended
and how that was different from the
movie on earth night owl and Rorschach
are going around trying to uncover this
conspiracy that they think that awesome
and iasts is behind Rorschach writes
everything down in a journal and then
mails it to the new frontiersman
newspaper there's sort of a tag scene at
the end of the series where it seems
like they're going to publish that and
reveal all the secrets of Ozymandias as
larger plan undoing everything that he
tried to do eventually they discover
Ozymandias and his antarctic retreat and
he tells them about his plan to unite
humanity against a common enemy that
common enemy being dr. Manhattan
eventually dr. Manhattan comes back to
earth witnesses all the destruction and
finds out that Ozymandias has been
blocking his ability to see into the
future with tachyons when he confronts
Ozymandias Ozymandias gives him his case
for humanity and why it's necessary to
blame him for everything so that
humanity could
dances of species the way that it needs
to dr. Manhattan who's lost most of his
humanity as he's become more and more
godlike actually agrees with Ozymandias
but Rorschach isn't having any of it he
tells them that you'll have to kill me
in order to prevent me from revealing
the lies that you've been telling
everyone
so dr. Manhattan big WTF moment kills
Rorschach because he thinks that it's
for the betterment of human society then
as he says at the end of the movie and
at the end of the comic book he's going
to leave to attempt to create some new
life somewhere else implying that he's
going to be leaving the solar system in
going to another part of the universe
his parting words are nothing ever ends
and they've actually been using that
sentence to market the series so
obviously dr. Manhattan still very
important to the story of the new modern
series the main difference between the
end of the original comic series in the
movie is that they substituted the giant
space squid because they felt like that
was too weird for non comic-book
audiences for a giant nuclear seeming
bomb meant to mimic the powers of dr.
Manhattan so the energy signature would
read like it was him who was causing the
explosion once we actually get into the
episodes I will reference moments from
the comic books when they come up as
Easter eggs in episodes if you feel like
it's too much to actually go back and
read the original comic series they
actually did a pretty decent motion
comic it received a lot of criticism
because the design wasn't great but they
actually did adapt the entire comic
series into a big motion comic condoning
or condemning human affairs cannot be my
concern I'm leaving this galaxy for one
less complicated but you've regained
interest in human life yes I have
I think perhaps I'll create some goodbye
John wait I did the right thing didn't I
it all worked out in the end in the end
nothing ends Adrian nothing ever end
John wait
what do you mean by just like the
original series was a very realistic
hard look at our relationship a society
with vigilantes it's the same thing with
the new Watchmen series just updated
with more modern context so they have
some modern technology but not others
there are some weird things happening in
present day just because of the way
things unfolded after the events of the
original Watchmen comic book series so
there's no internet
nobody has smartphones because they've
been outlawed and because presidential
term limits were abolished in the
original series Robert Redford
succeeded Nixon as US president and has
been president for the last 30 plus
years even guns have been outlawed but
because we have dr. Manhattan in this
world there was a lot of science and
technology that they adapted from his
abilities so they do have some advanced
technology there are a lot of characters
that they bring back from the original
comic book series dr. Manhattan is still
a very important character to the series
you have an older version of Silk
Spectre and you have Ozymandias and
obviously there's a lot of mysteries
that they have not revealed that we'll
find out about in later episodes so I'm
assuming that they included a lot more
stuff from the original series the main
antagonist when the series picks up as
the trailers have all told you are the
people wearing this war Shack mask they
call them the seventh Cavalry the 7th
Calvary carries out a giant hit on the
police department so they outlaw
vigilantes the only people that are
legally allowed to wear masks are people
that work for the police department or
other law enforcement agencies Regina
Kings character takes up the persona
sister night when she's in her vigilante
costume instance about the task of
taking down the seventh cavalry as she
starts to unravel the mystery behind the
seventh cavalry they start to unfurl
more and more Easter eggs from the
classic comic book series making it
bigger and bigger obviously this is
meant to be a 9 episode series so
they're gonna answer most of the big
questions in the finale but whereas the
earlier trailers make it seem like it's
a pretty simple situation where the cult
of Rorschach maybe got their hands on
Rorschach's journal from the original
series you also
this very dr. Manhattan's symbol behind
lorry looking like they're getting ready
to brainwash her or interrogate her
making it seem like they're more
obsessed with dr. Manhattan than they
are with were shacks Journal genes smart
was great as the older version of Laurie
Blake aka so expect her in obviously
Jeremy Irons is fantastic as the older
Ozymandias you don't know exactly what's
going on with his character right away
but that's part of the larger mystery
that they unfurled as episodes go on
even though Alan Moore's material that
they're adapting is super dense and
laced with meaning you could deconstruct
it for years and it has been
deconstructed for many years the pacing
in the first episode is fantastic they
don't throw too much at you too fast
obviously I'll be doing Easter egg
videos so I'm we're really looking
forward to rewatching the first episode
Don Johnson is fantastic I was actually
surprised when he was cast he's not
playing a character from the original
series but he does have a lot of good
scenes with Laurie Blake and with Regina
King's character they do this weird
thing in the first episode - were they
open with a giant flashback that you've
seen in all the trailers - the original
race riots from the 1920s in Tulsa
Oklahoma so a lot of the series at least
at first takes place in and around
modern-day Tulsa Oklahoma is mundane as
that might sound you have to remember
that this is a world where dr. Mann
hadn't existed so there are a lot of
fantastical things and big mysteries
that appear during the first episode but
part of the fun is taking Angela's
perspective as she's sort of learning
about the world of Watchmen and learning
about these larger conspiracies like Lou
Gossett Jr's character tells her a
wide-ranging conspiracy that would blow
your mind and if you didn't hear the
good news earlier this year Trent Reznor
and Atticus Ross are doing the music for
the series that's right you're getting
Alan Moore story set to Nine Inch Nails
music it's really haunting and really
amazing at the same time it's perfect it
was a great choice to pick them I've
only seen the first episode so I can't
say too much about the other Easter eggs
that they include from the comic book
but like I said I'm expecting to find a
lot more as we get on in episodes the
way they designed the series to was to
be relatively self-contained to the
first season so all the big mysteries
that they set up in the first couple of
episodes they will answer by the finale
I did think it was kind of weird that
they only went for nine episodes instead
of ten but I think part of the idea is
is they wanted to air all of the
episodes before the Christmas holidays
so there won't be any kind of break in
the middle of the season I
they'll probably enjoyed a little bit
more than I enjoyed Westworld just
because I'm a little bit more of a comic
book person and there's so much comic
book in this series also happening
really soon too is the Mandalorian
series on Disney Plus that's going to be
launching November 12
but it'll be a Friday show for all the
rest of the episodes this is actually
the episode scheduled for that so I will
be doing Watchmen and Star Wars
Mandalorian episode videos all season
long for the rest of the year
and if you're a really big fan of The
Witcher series there's also new Witcher
episodes that will be premiering a
little bit later I believe in December
so there's actually a lot of really cool
stuff coming up before the end of the
year if you have any big questions about
the series that you want me to include
in videos just let me know in the
comments but my episode 1 Easter Egg
video my top 10 WTF that we'll post this
Sunday night so as long as you have
alerts enabled for my channel you should
see that when I post it while you wait
for everything click here for that brand
new witcher netflix trailer video and
click here for my Mandalorian Star Wars
trailer video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight